every time Netflix that's another tween
dramedy to their service you have to
wonder where are all the good movies
well they're there they just take some
digging from chilling horror films to
quirky comedies and Netflix is filled
with great movie selections if you know
where to look he has a roundup of some
of the best Netflix hidden gems you
probably haven't seen yeah in order of
disappearance
you'll be rooting for the underdog in
this hard-boiled crime thriller straight
from the snowy streets of Norway
starring stellan skarsgård and the Game
of Thrones as Christopher have you in
order of disappearance follows a quiet
seemingly average snow plow operator on
a quest to avenge the murder of his son
equal parts pitch black comedy and
explosive revenge thriller in the order
of disappearances as in stoppable as its
protagonist as the New York Times review
put it it's somewhere between Fargo and
Quinton Tarantino and the end result is
way more fun than it should be
hello well he can't actually talk right
now because he's he's dead officer down
let's just preface this by saying that
you shouldn't expect a whole lot from
officer down based on the 2010 graphic
novel the movie is a hyper stylized
splatter fest about a cop who can't die
well he can he just comes back to life
again that's about it as far as plot
goes there's a criminal organization
that dresses like animals some
gun-toting nuns and a clan of ninja type
people and I should expect they all take
turns trading blows with undead super
cop officer down
fortunately the movie doesn't ask or
expect the viewer to take any of this
seriously
it doesn't even ask you to care all that
much about who these people are
all it really wants us to have gunfights
and explosions and in that respect it
does okay just turn off your brain and
let down take care of the rest
Ava's possessions just when you thought
the demonic possession genre had been
exorcised of all traces of originality
along comes Ava's possessions a twist on
the trope that looks at life after a
possession happens it's a fresh take on
the whole possession thing drawing a
satirical parallel between people who
have been possessed and alcoholics
support groups in all my name is ava my
uninvited spiritual guest possessed me
for 28 days and was exercised on Tuesday
if you're looking for something else of
the ordinary to spend an evening with or
just in the mood to find some bleeped
comedy in the unlikeliest of places you
could definitely do a lot worse
war on everyone for all of its unlikable
characters war on everyone is a
surprisingly enjoyable movie the main
characters are Terry and Bob played by
Alexander Skarsgard and Michael Pena
respectively two crooked cops with
absolutely no moral code instead of
stopping crimes they spend their days
blackmailing criminals in exchange for
kickbacks this is technically a buddy
cop comedy but the black humour and
overall message that nothing really
matters take it to some weird places and
yet somehow by the time the last bullets
have found their mark you realize that
you kind of like these two amoral sleaze
bags you haven't performed one single
act of redemption the whole movie war on
everyone won't hit home with everybody
but if you like dark humour you may find
yourself enjoying it a little more than
you should
moon you may know Duncan Jones as a
director from recent films like mute or
Warcraft but in 2009 Jones released his
debut film moon a low-budget sci-fi gem
that pulled in less than 10 million
dollars at the box office starring Sam
Rockwell and the robot who sounds like
Kevin Spacey it's a definition of a
bottle movie just one man in a lunar
research station slowly losing his mind
he goes banannie it parties or anything
of course
any trailer will tell you that there's a
little more to it than that but we're
not trying to spoil anything here if
you've never seen moon do yourself a
favor and avoid all the marketing and
just queue it up on Netflix a perfect
day it was a simple job just get the
corpse out of the well but nothing is
ever simple for this group of aid
workers during the yuccas love was but
set on all sides by uptight to UN
bureaucrats gun-toting kids and the
previous Cal's all they want to do is
find a piece of rope so they can pull a
body out of a local town's water supply
before it poisons the villagers with a
cast led by Benicio del Toro Tim Robbins
and Melanie Tyree a perfect day is both
an absurd comedy of errors and a low-key
satire of the regulations and red tape
involved in international conflict
without making any grand statements the
movie suggests a parallel between the
main characters small-scale mission and
the larger surrounding war if it's this
hard to find a rope how is an entire
country supposed to figure out his
problems blame there seem to be two
camps when it comes to this Netflix
animated film those who like the
original manga hate the movie
those who haven't read the manga
generally enjoyed it but love it or hate
it when it comes to fresh takes on the
apocalypse blame has most any other
futuristic vision beats hands down
that's what makes this film so
intriguing in a seemingly endless
continually growing city that goes from
miles up town and in either direction
robots have taken to exterminating
humans but a small band of people have
survived for centuries inside an
invisible shield that keeps the robots
out they don't know why their robots
can't get inside their colony they just
know that going outside means risking
life and limb at the hands of predatory
robots it's only when a stranger comes
to their town that they realized there
may be a chance to do something about
their predicament and finally stop the
expansion of the city the vision alone
blame is well worth watching the vault
James Franco headlines the vault as the
assistant manager of a bang that gets
knocked over by a group of petty thieves
the twist is the bank is haunted when
Franco leads this heist gang into the
underground vaults they get more than
money they get ghosts
you won't be rocking back and forth in
terror from the vaults although it does
have its chilling moments you won't end
up rooting for the thieves although it
does open them up to empathy eventually
and you definitely won't be chuckling at
James Franco silly antics because he's a
stone-faced mustachioed man on a mission
once things really get going
but the vault lacks and such departments
as characterization script and suspense
and more than makes up for in ghosts
bunches of ghosts if you love ghosts
you'll easily tolerate the vault cold in
July starring Michael C hall and Sam
Shepard cold in July begins with a choir
a family man who shoots a burglar in his
house soon though his family is being
terrorized by the departed young man's
angry father who's fresh out of prison
and out for revenge
well that alone would make for an
interesting if predictable film cold in
July quickly switches gears as these two
men realize that there are bigger stakes
involved than their petty revenge tale
one of cold in July's biggest strengths
is that you never guess where the story
is going next each new twisted
development takes the characters in an
entirely new direction if there's a
downside to the whole thing it's that
the ending is over a little too quickly
but it's not enough to ruin what's
otherwise a solid engaging movie oculus
Netflix has a million-and-a-half horror
movies and the vast majority of them
aren't exactly gems hidden or otherwise
oculus looks a lot like the rest of them
when you're scrolling through Netflix
but with one teensy important difference
it's actually pretty great a brother and
sister return to the house where their
father murdered their mother bringing
along the haunted mirror that made him
do it
their plan is to record themselves being
driven crazy by the mirror so the whole
world knows that an evil mirror is
responsible for that horrible crime back
in the day even the description sounds a
little silly but oculus is that one rare
gem that pulls it off
[Music]
oculus was one of writer and director
Mike Flanagan's first films of the
decent budget and it shows in every
frame Sanna gun has since gone on to
direct several other films including one
of those Ouija movies that were
everywhere in 2016 and Netflix is
Gerald's game adaptation so his is
definitely a name you'll be hearing
about more often in the future Full
Metal Alchemist is a live-action version
of for metal alchemist as good as the
anime not even close but is it cheesy
and hilarious
and full of ridiculous moments oh you
bear for newcomers to the whole thing
the story is about two brothers with a
natural inclination for alchemy who
attempt to bring their mother back to
life things go horribly wrong and one
brother ends up with his soul trapped in
a suit of armor while the other loses an
arm and a leg when they're older they
search for the mythical Philosopher's
Stone in the hopes of restoring their
bodies as far as anime adaptations go
Full Metal Alchemist is arguably one of
the best out there it doesn't cover the
whole story
but it serves as an origin tale and
works as a self-contained story but even
non fans can enjoy at least you could
enjoy if you like over-the-top action
fantasies that's all this is super dark
times this coming-of-age story has all
the staples of the genre high school
friends teenage drama house parties and
pubescent angst but for two best friends
a traumatic experience may be too much
for them to reconcile in his feet to
length debut director kevin phillips has
crafted a tight unique teenage thriller
the rich atmosphere and superb
performances from a relatively unknown
cast add weight to an already heavy
script this isn't an easy movie to watch
although other films may be more
gratuitously violent a super dark times
doesn't offer a hint of escapism in its
few brutal moments if you're looking for
light-hearted viewing it'd be better off
queueing up something else but if you
want to experience a superb film with a
dramatic message you could do worse than
super dark times a serious man
even by Coen Brothers standards a
serious man is an unusual movie it
starts with a subtitled prologue set in
the 19th century and then moves into a
suburb in the Midwest a circa the late
60s the main character is Larry Gopnik a
Jewish physics professor so am i right
so okay so so if that's that and we can
do this when gopnik's life starts being
derailed by a chain of events completely
beyond this control he visits three
rabbis to figure out the meaning of life
it's not the Cohen's best movie by a
long shot or even their best comedy in
the end you'll probably come away
scratching your head but maybe you'll
also watch it again a year later because
there's something there something you
can't put your finger on there has to be
something holding it all together or
maybe just maybe none of it means
anything
okay the uncertainty principle it proves
we can't ever really know what's going
on thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're lifting
[Music]